so I have a Facebook friend whose life
seems perfect she lives in a gorgeous
house and she's a really rewarding
career and she and her family go on all
these exciting adventures together on
the weekends and I swear that they must
take a professional photographer along
with them because no matter where they
go or what they do the whole family just
looks beautiful
and she's always posting about how
blessed she is and how grateful she is
for the life that she has and I get the
feeling she's not just saying those
things for the sake of Facebook but she
truly means it how many of you have a
friend kind of like that and how many of
you kinda don't like that person
sometimes we all do this right it's hard
not to do but that way of thinking costs
us something and that's what I want to
talk to you about today is what our bad
habits cost us maybe you scroll through
your facebook feed and you think what if
I roll my eyes it's just five seconds of
my time how could it be hurting me well
researchers have found that envying your
friends on Facebook actually leads to
depression that's just one of the traps
that our minds can set for us have you
ever complained about your boss or
looked at your friends lives and thought
why do they have all the luck can't help
thinking that way right that way of
thinking seems small in the moment in
fact it might even make you feel better
in the moment but that way of thinking
is eating away at your mental strength
there's three kinds of destructive
beliefs that make us less effective and
robbed us of our mental strength
the first one is unhealthy beliefs about
ourselves we tend to feel sorry for
ourselves and while it's okay to be sad
when something bad happens self-pity
goes beyond that it's when you start to
magnify your misfortune when you think
things like why do these things always
have to happen to me I shouldn't have to
deal with it that way of thinking keeps
you stuck keeps you focused on the
problem keeps you from perfect from
finding a solution and even when you
can't create a solution you can always
take steps to make your life or somebody
else's life better but you can't do that
when you're busy hosting your own pity
party the second type of destructive
belief that holds us back is unhealthy
beliefs about others we think that other
people can control us and we give away
our power but as adults who live in a
free country there's very few things in
life that you have to do so when you say
I have to work late you give away your
power
yeah maybe there'll be consequences if
you don't work late but it's still a
choice or when you say my mother-in-law
drives me crazy you give away your power
maybe she's not the nicest person on
earth but it's up to you how you respond
to her because you're in control the
third type of unhealthy belief that
holds us back is unhealthy beliefs about
the world we tend to think that the
world owes us something we think if I
put in enough hard work then I deserve
success but expecting success to fall
into your lap like some sort of cosmic
reward will only lead to disappointment
but I know it's hard to give up our bad
mental habits it's hard to get rid of
those unhealthy beliefs that we've
carried around with us for so long but
you can't afford not to give them up
because sooner or later you're gonna hit
a time in your life where you need all
the mental strength that you can muster
when I was 23 years old I thought I had
life all figured out I graduated from
grad school I landed my first big
job as a therapist I got married and I
even bought a house and I thought this
is gonna be great I've got this
incredible jumpstart on success what
could go wrong that all changed for me
one day when I got a phone call from my
sister she said that our mother was
found unresponsive and she'd been taken
to the hospital my husband Lincoln and I
jumped in the car and rushed to the
hospital we couldn't imagine what could
be wrong
my mother is only 51 she didn't have any
history of heart of any kind of health
problems when we got to the hospital
doctors explained she'd had a brain
aneurism and within 24 hours my mother
who used to wake up in the morning
saying it's a great day to be alive
passed away that news was devastating to
me
my mother and I had been very close as a
therapist and you want to intellectual
level how to go through grief but
knowing it and doing it can be two very
different things
it took a long time before I felt like I
was really healing and then on the
three-year anniversary of my mother's
death some friends called and invited
Lincoln and me to a basketball game
coincidentally it was being played at
the same auditorium
Brett last seen my mother on the night
before she passed away I hadn't been
back there since I wasn't even sure I
wanted to go back but Lincoln and I
talked about it and ultimately we said
maybe that'll be a good way to honor her
memory so we went to the game and we
actually had a really good time with our
friends on the drive home that night we
talked about how great it was to finally
be able to go back to that place and
remember my mother with a smile rather
than all those feelings of sadness
shortly after we got home that night
Lincoln said he didn't feel well a few
minutes later he collapsed I had to call
for an ambulance
his family met me at the emergency room
we waited for what seemed like forever
till finally a doctor came out but
rather than taking us out back to see
Lincoln he took us back to a private
room and sat us down and explained to us
that Lincoln
it was the most adventurous person I'd
ever met was gone we didn't know at that
time but he'd had a heart attack
he was only 26 he didn't have any
history of heart problems so now I found
myself a 26-year old widow and I didn't
have my mom I thought how am I gonna get
through this and to describe that as a
painful period in my life feels like an
understatement and it was during that
time that I realized when you're really
going through tough times good habits
aren't enough it only takes one or two
small habits to really hold you back I
worked as hard as I could not just to
create good habits in my life but to get
rid of those small habits no matter how
small they might seem throughout it all
I held out hope that someday life could
get better and eventually it did you
gears down the road I met Steve and we
fell in love and I got remarried we sold
the house that Lincoln and I had lived
in and we bought a new house in a new
area and I got a new job but almost as
quickly as I breathe my sigh of relief
over that fresh start that I had we got
the news that Steve's dad had terminal
cancer and I started to think why do
these things always have to keep
happening why do I have to keep losing
all my loved ones this isn't fair
but if I'd learned anything it was that
that way of thinking would hold me back
I knew what I was going to need as much
mental strength as I could muster to get
through one more loss so I sat down and
I wrote a list of all the things
mentally strong people don't do and I
read over that list
it was a reminder of all of those bad
habits that I've done at one time or
another
that would keep me stuck and I kept
reading that list over and over and I
really needed it because within a few
weeks of writing it Steve's dad passed
away my journey taught me but the secret
to being mentally strong is that you
have to give up your bad mental habits
mental strength is a lot like physical
strength if you wanted to be physically
strong you need to go to the gym and
lift weights but if you really wanted to
see results you'd also have to give up
eating junk food mental strength is the
same if you want to be mentally strong
you need good habits like practicing
gratitude but you also have to give up
bad habits like presenting somebody
else's success no matter how often that
happens it'll hold you back
so how do you train your brain to think
differently how do you give up those bad
mental habits that you've carried around
with you it starts by countering those
unhealthy beliefs that I talked about
with healthier ones for example
unhealthy beliefs about ourselves mostly
come about because we're uncomfortable
with our feelings feeling sad or hurt or
angry or scared those things are all
uncomfortable so we go to great lengths
to avoid that discomfort we try to
escape it by doing things like hosting a
pity party and although that's a
temporary distraction it just prolongs
the pain the only way to get through
uncomfortable emotions the only way to
get deal with them I said you have to go
through them to let yourself feel sad
and then move on to gain confidence in
your ability to deal with that
discomfort unhealthy beliefs about
others come about because we compare
ourselves to other people we think that
they're either above us or below us we
think that they can control how we feel
or that we can control how they behave
or we blame them for holding
back but really it's our own choices
that do that you have to accept that
you're your own person and other people
are separate from you the only person
you should compare yourself to is the
person that you were yesterday and
unhealthy beliefs about the world come
about because deep down we want the
world to be fair we no want to think
that if we put in enough good deeds
enough good things will happen to us or
if we tough it out through enough bad
times we'll get some sort of reward but
ultimately you have to accept that life
isn't fair
and that can be liberating it means you
won't necessarily be rewarded for your
goodness but it also means no matter how
much you've suffered you're not doomed
to keep suffering the world doesn't work
that way your world is what you make it
but of course before you can change your
world you have to believe that you can
change it and once worked through this
man who'd been diabetic for years his
doctor referred him to therapy because
he had some bad mental habits that were
starting to affect his physical health
his mother had died from complications
of diabetes at a young age so he just
believed he was doomed and he'd given up
trying to manage his blood sugar
altogether in fact his blood sugar had
gotten so high lately that it was
starting to affect his vision and he had
his driver's license taken away and his
world was shrinking when he came into my
office it was clear he knew all the
things he could do to manage his blood
sugar he just didn't think it was worth
the effort
but eventually he agreed to make one
small change he said I'll give up my two
liter a day Pepsi habit and I'll trade
it in for Diet Pepsi and he couldn't
believe how quickly his numbers started
to improve and even though he came in
every week to remind me how horrible
Diet Pepsi tasted he stuck with it
and once he started to see a little bit
of improvement he said well maybe I
could look at some of my other habits
and he said I could trade in my nightly
bowl of ice cream first snack with a
little less sugar and then one day he
was at a thrift store with some friends
and he found this beat-up old exercise
bike he bought it for a couple of bucks
and he brought it home and he parked it
in front of his TV and he started to
peddle while he'd watch some of his
favorite shows every night and not only
did he lose weight but one day he
noticed he could see the TV just a
little bit more clearly than he had
before and suddenly it occurred to him
maybe the damage done to his eyesight
wasn't permanent so he set a new goal
for himself to get his driver's license
back and from that day forward he was on
fire by the end of our time together he
was coming in every week saying okay
what are we gonna do this week because
he finally believed that he could change
his world and that he had the mental
strength to change it and that he could
give up his bad mental habits and it all
started which is one small step so I
invite you to consider what bad mental
habits are holding you back well
unhealthy beliefs are keeping you from
being as mentally strong as you could be
and what's one small step that you could
take today right here right now thank
you